Daniel is with us in New Hampshire hi
Daniel how are you
whoops gotta push the button Dave try
again Daniel how are you not bad how are
you Dave better than I deserve
how can I help I guess make a long story
short a while back I've been listening
to you for better part of a year now and
you know I heard everything and it made
sense to me I wanted to jump right in
brought it up with my wife and she
immediately shot it down had zero
interest in participating we went back
and forth for a while and we appear to
see very differently on how to use money
we can't really agree on finances at all
fast forward to last week she asked me
if we could buy something for the house
and I said well I don't have money for
right now we don't have the money for
right now and she said well I have
twelve thousand dollars in a savings
account that you didn't know about can
we use that money and I'm not really
sure how to deal with that situation of
her hiding that amount of money from me
well I can tell you that most people
would think that that was under the
level of deception in most marriages
I would I would have a serious problem
of integrity breach if my wife were to
do that and I think most people view it
that way and so you're probably having a
little of those feelings when a spouse
hides debt or a spouse hides savings in
our world depending on how extreme it is
and how long it's going on and those
kinds of things that you know a lot of
people on our world call that financial
infidelity because it's a breach of
trust and it feels almost like
infidelity and so you know you're
probably having at least some of those
feelings aren't you yeah yeah so the
thing is this money problems are never
the problem they're always the symptom
of something that's going on including
if I if I'm just a single person I have
money problems what are what's causing
the money problem because the money
problems not it's usually revealing
something else that's going on and so
what's this revealing in your all's
relationship that's what I would really
be digging on rather than the acts
a tactical fact that there's $12,000
over there is she planning her escape is
are you controlling to the point that
she thinks she can't breathe
is there a breach of trust in the past
that's never been healed between you all
is she having an affair I don't know who
needs to hide $12,000 from their husband
there's you need to find out why
right there's something some reason that
someone would do something that's that
dysfunctional because it's dysfunctional
and you know you maybe may reveal
something about you you don't like that
you've been a twerp and overbearing
control freak or something you know I'm
not saying that I'm just saying these
are the types of things that could enter
into that does that make sense to you
yeah and so I would treat this like she
was having an emotional affair with a
personal trainer maybe they have slept
together but this is a major breach of
trust and so we need to be in the
marriage counselors office to survive
and to cause our marriage relationship
to prosper because something's broken
here that the two of you haven't been
dealing with probably for some time that
is that is that is that is that you
think I'm overstating that no I think
that sounds correct what we've been
fighting about a lot recently so I'm not
a lot of other things - yeah pretty much
everything
yeah yeah okay how long you been married
a little over a year oh okay all right
what's the nature of most of your fights
a lot of money and a lot of she feels
like I don't do enough around the house
mm-hmm okay I would say the mean - yeah
so if you were just gonna have a
two-minute conversation which is all
we've had not enough to really find out
what the flips going on but if you just
tell me those things with that pieces of
information this $12,000 is security for
her because she feels very insecure in
the situation she's not sure this is
like that gonna last so it's an escape
pod mm-hmm that's what it is
and and then you gotten a real heated
argument and and she's really trying to
force her will on the situation which is
this item she wants to buy and so she
probably revealed something she never
had any intention of revealing mmm-hmm
in the heat of the I mean so I mean you
know I talked with my pastor probably a
week and a half ago about all this and
he said look you need to you need keep
your cool stay calm
sure that you can show that you're not
um trying to meet you're not trying to
be mean you're trying to make things
better and let things cool off before
we're going to be able to fix it well
I've been doing it things have hold off
we've been way more civil with each
other the past week so now I don't know
how to approach this one specific thing
without undoing you know that only a
week I wouldn't watch the one thing ask
your pastor what he thinks but my guess
is if I were in your shoes you know what
I would probably end up doing is just
saying hey look this money thing is one
thing this hidden account is another
thing our other disagreements are
another thing I mean we have to both
agree this has not been a dream line the
marriage in the past twelve months and
I'd like to go to the pastor and the two
of us sit down and start putting some
tools in our belt that neither one of us
have for doing better for each other I
know I certainly be a better husband and
I'm gonna go sit down and begin some
marriage counseling to do that on the
overall thing rather than I'm gonna drag
you before the pastor and have you
slaughtered for this $12,000 account
that that line won't work the other one
might work but yeah I mean really cuz
you just you guys need some help and she
probably is in agreement on that but if
she thinks she's being drug in to be
shamed for this one event that's one
thing she's not gonna go and she's not
gonna want to participate I wouldn't go
in on the singular issue I would just
say the singular issue is what caused me
to realize that the overall thing is
really getting bad and you know it's
probably part of my fault probably part
of your fault you may not think that but
I would really do know we need some help
because this is beyond our ability to
fix it by ourselves so let's begin some
good detailed marriage counseling let's
start meeting with the pastor and talk
to Pastor see if he thinks that's right
but I would sell the the marriage
counseling as an overall thing because
you do need it bad yeah
Amen I'm sorry sorry you're facing this
I don't I'm just a regular guy I'm not a
therapist or a counselor or anything
like that but I've been through a lot of
what you've been through and Sharon I
tried to kill each other when we went
broke so I've got experience with that
and I've been a jerk more than once in
38 years of marriage I can promise you
that Sharon says out of 38 years of
marriage we've had 25 good years so
probably a little too real for radio but
there